l'avenir de l'industrie automobile en
ile-de-france et le thème des travaux
que mènera demain le comité économique
et social
l'avenir pour le moins incertain on
estime la surcapacité à 20% pour les
voitures de tourisme
elle serait même de 40% en ce qui
concerne le poids lourd dans ces
conditions le seul maintien de l'emploi
à son niveau actuel sera déjà très
ambitieux l'exemple de renault
billancourt avec bernard sega
l'automobile reste un secteur clé de
l'activité en ile de france et pourtant
le développement de cette industrie
s'est surtout fait en province ça te
branche a perdu quelque 70 emplois en
dix ans par ailleurs la concurrence
internationale est de plus en plus
agressive
un site pour être rentable doit être
suffisamment vaste c'est le cas pour
poissy où pour ramener mais ce problème
se pose pour les sites de la petite
couronne et pour celui ô combien
symbolique de boulogne billancourt
pendant moderniser un site comme celui
de poissy on a construit puis moderniser
un site comme celui d'aulnay il est
difficile
honnêtement de penser que l'on puisse
moderniser un site comme celui de bill
en cours par exemple pour être clair
parce que pour faire une construction de
voitures normales il faudrait doubler la
superficie de billancourt or c'est
impossible donc les problèmes se posent
site par site
en petite couronne nous pensons qu'il
faut maintenir les sites changer faire
autre chose moderniser mais que le
développement si nous entrons dans une
production de grande série
c'est un développement en grande
couronne dans son rapport le comité
économique et social recommande aux
constructeurs le maintien de ses sites
même s'il est parfois tentant pour eux
de vendre de terra extrêmement convoité
surtout lorsqu'on a comme renault 60
milliards de dette
le rapport met également l'accent sur la
différence entre le taux de tva français
de 33 % et celui des allemands de 14%
enfin il recommande aux communes si vous
voulez conserver chez vous l'industrie
automobile ne l'assassiné pas avec des
taxes trop lourdes